und vor steuern ja es geht nämlich nicht
nur um posten es geht natürlich auch um
inhalte und wir wollen beim bild hier
den großen ampelcheck machen wir nehmen
uns mal einzelne punkte aus diesen
sondierungs papier vor und besprechen
die mit experten nehmen sie mal genauer
unter die lupe die ampel parteien wollen
ja zum beispiel keine steuererhöhungen
und auch keine neuen steuern genau und
darüber wollen wir jetzt mit dem
präsidenten des steuerzahlerbundes
sprechen reiner holznagel hallo herr
holznagel morgen guten morgen ich grüße
sie herr holznagel keine
steuererhöhungen steht im sondierungs
papier wie realistisch ist das glauben
sie dass das sondierungs papier ist ja
nur der anfang wir werden schauen wie im
koalitionsvertrag diese aussage
untermauert wird wir sind natürlich
dafür dass es keine steuererhöhungen
gibt und dass es auch keine neuen
steuern gibt und die koalition wird dann
beweisen müssen ob sie ihre versprechen
an dieser stelle hält allerdings haben
in der korona pandemie extrem viele
schulden gemacht wie sollen die denn
ohne neue steuern oder steuererhöhungen
bezahlt werden da haben sie recht wir
haben über 400 milliarden euro neue
schulden bekommen auf bundesebene
allerdings haben den letzten krisen
gesehen dass steuererhöhungen nicht dazu
beigetragen haben diese schulden
abzutragen sondern wirtschaftswachstum
insofern ist die fdp völlig auf den
richtigen weg zu sagen wir müssen die
rahmenbedingungen verbessern damit wir
mehr wirtschaftswachstum haben um am
ende natürlich auch mehr steuereinnahmen
einzunehmen klar ist natürlich auch
höhere steuersätze werden nicht höhere
einnahmen generieren das muss der
politik klar sein und vor allen dingen
ist es auch wichtig dass wir den
sparhaushalt uns mal angucken deswegen
erwarte ich von allen koalitionären wo
sie wirklich auch sparpakete schnüren
die cdu kritisiert ja bereits dass das
streichen von subventionen oder
abschreibungsmöglichkeiten letztendlich
auch eine versteckte steuererhöhungen
seien das ist genau richtig deswegen
müssen wir genau hinschauen was im
koalitionspapier steht das sondierungs
papier ist mit überschriften gefüllt die
sind aus meiner sicht schon mal richtig
aber wie das kleinklein am ende aussieht
das wird sehr entscheidend sein und sie
haben es eben schon auch angesprochen es
wird auch sehr wichtig sein wer welches
haus bekommt und wenn die grünen das f
das finanzministerium bekommen dann sehe
ich an vielen kleinigkeiten schon die
problematik dass die steuerschraube
angetan gezogen wird könnte das auch
nach abschluss eines koalitionsvertrags
noch passieren na ja nicht alles das
kennen wir aus den letzten koalition
steht im koalitionsvertrag es ist
natürlich die tägliche politik die
entscheidet und oftmals ist es auch so
dass das finanzministerium ohne das
parlament viele dinge entscheiden kann
ob es wegen durchführungsbestimmungen
sind ob es ausführungsbestimmungen sind
die finanzämter werden dementsprechend
handeln wie das finanzministerium es
vorgibt deswegen ist hier der drops
wirklich noch lange nicht gelutscht und
wir werden sehen wer welches haus
bekommt und wieder an die politik
aussieht vor allem die vermögenssteuer
wird nicht angehoben das war ja den
grünen und auch der spd sehr wichtig
halte sich das so richtig
absolut die vermögenssteuer ist
ausgesetzt worden von dem
bundesverfassungsgericht aus vielerlei
hinsicht wir haben hier einfach keine
chance eine gerechte und gleichmäßige
besteuerung durchzuführen zumal ist
bisher immer so gewesen im wahlkampf
dass immer nur die anderen die
vermögenssteuer zahlen aber tatsächlich
wird sie den mittelstand mittelschicht
treffen schon ab einer million euro das
hört sich viel an ist es aber gar nicht
wenn man schon alleine die
immobilienpreise sich anschaut deswegen
ist es richtig dass dieses projekt an
acta gelegt worden ist und ich hoffe es
bleibt auch wirklich da verschwunden
reiner holznagel dankeschön
bitte sehr
ja und wir sind gleich wieder damit
überwachungsvideos aus dem westin hotel
leipzig die ein völlig neues licht auf
den fall klären
[Musik]